[Music]
read printed documents with seeing a eye
seeing a eyes document channel enables
you to read the text of a document now
OCR has been around for quite some time
however with the mobile phone taking a
picture of a document can be quite
challenging to help with this we detect
the edges of the document and provide
guidance on how to position the phone
and once we recognize the text in the
document we go one step further by also
detecting the formatting which enables
you to navigate more easily using voice
overs and navigation commands so here I
have a document and as I put the phone
over it no edge is visible I hear that
no edge is a visible wrap in left edge
is not visible because it has detected
the presence of the document and
straightaway it's giving me guidance and
you also had said the other two edges
weren't visible etc instead of just
moving the phone around and manually
taking a picture I'm going to use a
different technique which I personally
find to be useful which is to put the
camera in the center of the document and
the camera remember is not in the middle
of the phone but in the top right corner
normally so let's do that now edge is
visible and making sure it stays
parallel I'm going to lift the sign up
left edge not visible I'm going to keep
moving away
processing and it took the photo itself
standard lease agreement heading level
one great sets recognize the text it
sounds pretty accurate and you heard it
say heading level one because it has
also understood the formatting and
that's great because I can use voiceover
to navigate by headings for example just
to give you an idea of how accurate it
is I'm going to swipe through a bit more
of this document this agreement is
executed on May 5th 2017 by in-between
I'm going to pause it there it's a
boring legal document but I have that
gives you an idea so there we have it
reading a document with seeing AI
Microsoft logo appears